you
welcome back to a video on code Tech and
toriel's today we are continuing the old
cpp for school series basically this is
just going through a bunch of C++
questions and solutions and implementing
the solutions that comes from all comes
from this website we've done a bunch of
them in the past we're up to flow of
control still in set one and we're up to
problem nine so last episode we ended at
question eight and to do this I am using
cygwin as our terminal that way I can
use a GCC compiler use whatever you want
it should be about all the same and just
get you know just for reference I'll
show just say one it's easy to find just
google it you'll find it and also using
I'm using Visual Studio code to do the
coding so I'm kind of trying to take
each of these sets per file
so I just have a main where I've done
question 1 2 3 etc and a comment amount
of after I'm done all the way up to
problem 9 and I'm gonna do that first
and I'm going to show you problem 10 and
we'll see how much time we have left so
welcome aboard and as you can see let me
just I guess I'll get this out of the
way here let's look at question 9 so it
says write a program to calculate the
monthly telephone bills as per the
following rule minimum R's
200 for up to 100 calls plus ours 60
cents per call for the next 50 calls
Plus ours 50 cents per call for the next
50 calls plus ours 40% call for any call
beyond 200 calls I'm gonna be honest
with you I have no idea what our is mean
I've no clue I'm guessing it's just a
variable and they just decided to call
it ours I don't know beats me anyway
let's code up the solution so we
basically just want to calculate a
telephone bill and then we just need to
follow this logic so just to for
clarity's sake this is just a main I've
just got everything common stale there's
nothing else going on next until what we
start typing here right at question 9
write a program to calculate the monthly
bills per
as per the following so it looks like
they're just getting billed per call not
a minute not per minute minimum are is
200 for up to 100 calls what the heck
does that mean what am I supposed to
know is any what does anyone know saying
we know what that means even minimum RS
200 for up to 100 calls what I literally
have to look at this solution because I
have no clue what they mean by ours all
right sorry I don't I don't like looking
at these solutions but you gotta ask for
clarification if you need it if calls is
less than or equal to 100 their bills
200 sounds like an absolute ripoff else
if calls is greater than 100 less than
150 I still know it R is this but we'll
go with the guess cost is it cost what a
nightmare
cheese all right sometimes I read these
questions and think am i dumb and you
know maybe it's just something no one's
ever explained to me or something but
how is anyone supposed to know what RS
means minimum arse
it's a cost price bill give me something
that go on here minimum 200 for up to
100 calls
minimum pars 200 for up to 100 calls
just trying to think of a way to word
this that actually makes sense but I'm
not sure I understand it well I think
what they mean is if you have less than
100 calls your bills 200 okay how would
I ever get that out of the way they
worded this okay
well first of all let me just say this
is obviously a very easy problem and a
very easy thing to code up it's just
some basic how many here's the rate the
problem here is someone doesn't know how
to type in plain English that's that's
the problem here so that's the real
problem the problem isn't even is isn't
even a programming question this is a
can you figure out someone's absolutely
butchered English apparently I don't
know just guessing all right so let's
declare a float called ours and we'll
just assign it 0 all right and we'll
call design an integer or make an
integer called calls all right I'm gonna
start at a zero we're gonna do a whereas
the user how many calls all right and
then we're gonna ask for that input
standard see n calls all right so that's
easy and then based on how many calls we
want to do some calculations if calls is
greater than or equal to 100 RS
what equals one equals two honor that's
how they have in their solution but I'm
really having such a hard time
understanding the concept of what the
heck they mean by ours use a real
variable name
you
minimum or I'm looking at the solution I
give up
I honestly give up cuz I just don't
understand what they're trying to say I
just it's not even comprehendible just
make it frigging simple like you know
they just mean bill so let's just
pretend this RS says bill minimum bill
200 for up to 100 calls that's a buck
per call on an absolute ripoff cheese
I'm understanding this right that's a
buck per call right two bucks per call
or even more all right Shh I just can't
stand the way this is written the way
this is worded I know I've been saying
that for minutes but it's literally
blowing my mind and is so badly written
all right fine
so your monthly bills 200 bucks even if
you made zero calls okay don't pay this
company cancel your service whatever and
no one's gonna ever work with this
company they're so bad let's just be
fair about that let's ignore that let's
just program it all right
so if the calls is less than hundred we
just said no what no matter what you're
getting billed 200 bucks we start this
at 200 we don't need to check you sign
up for the service you get billed 200
bucks all right that's it
because worst service ever that's why
all right so if the calls is greater
than okay so next 50 calls so I'll call
101 to call 150 our 60 cents per call
all right so if calls is greater than or
equal to 150 we're going to say
RS we're gonna add some to it in the
amount we're going to add here the plus
equals just adds to RS here and sets it
equal to whatever we are adding to it
I'm gonna put it all in parenthesis here
whatever we're adding to it so it would
basically be 150 minus the number of
calls so we know that there is let's see
I gotta fix this a little bit calls
greater than 100 and less than 150 less
than or equal to 150 let's just make
sure we got this right okay so there's
more than 100 calls but less than 150
calls then we're gonna add to this 200
dollar bill that you start out with
which I put in the wrong place and the
amount we're gonna add to it is let's
see we're gonna think about this here 60
cents per call over on him over that
okay so we just need to take calls - the
100 that we've already got because
that's up to the 200 dollar bill and
then whatever's left is 60 cents each
right so it says 60 cents okay
so the first hundred or already
accounted for so that's why you know
that's the first 200 dollar bill and
then all the way up to 150 is 60 cents
but then we also want to calculate
and the next 50 so we can do this with
an else--if and it'll essentially be
about the same thing here there's
there's a lot of ways I'm thinking you
could do this but we'll just we'll just
do it a set of three cases I think
that'll be easiest I'll just build these
cases real quick yeah no it just look
like this alright so if you're in
between 150 just get this 60 cents added
for a call up 250 if you're over 150 and
all the way to 200 and you're gonna get
another 50 cents added for each of these
calls so this original one still applies
and this new one yeah let's see we just
have to we have to make a more
complicated calculation basically so we
still gotta charge for the first 50
calls which is our the first 50 calls
over 100 which is basically just gonna
be 50 times 0.6 right so we got to add
the 101 call to 150 and then we also
have to add whatever is left going up to
200 because maybe they didn't get quite
200 well they probably didn't so it's
calls - for 150 here so however many
calls they have in this 150 range to 200
we got a times that by 0.5 all right
very good
and I'll just I'll just profusely use
parentheses sometimes it helps you
understand what's getting calculated
first and second etc because the
innermost is what gets done first so if
this would do this calculation and then
this calculation and then this
calculation and then it would add
together so that should give a correct
result and just make sure we got the
number of parentheses correct I think we
got one too many so we'll get rid of
that one
okay and for this last one this is the
calls over 200 so first of all we do
have to charge them for ya the first 50
over 100 times 0.6 them all so we're
gonna charge them for the next 50 times
0.5 that's all the way up to 200 and now
they are over 200 we do know that for
sure so we just need to add and the last
amount in and that amount is going to be
very similar to what we've been doing
except is gonna be minus 200
so we've already calculated and
calculated and those 200 calls and that
is a times point for there we go so that
should give us this solution now I just
want to walk through it one last time
we'll spit it out here cost of calls
cost of however many calls equals and
we'll just spit out the number RS let's
put a little new line at the end of this
that's a little more readable so there
we go now we can tell it how many calls
we made and it'll just give you the
price now these if elses for flow
control it's only gonna hit one of these
cases we could design this in a way
where it flows through and does the
calculation one at a time but in this
case we had to keep re plugging in this
calculation because it's only gonna hit
one of these cases so they make over 200
calls it's only gonna do this
calculation today or you're between 150
and 200 it's only gonna do this
calculation they're between 150 it's
only gonna do this one and if they're
less than 100 it's not going to execute
any of these and they're just gonna get
charge of that flat amount of 200 still
don't know what RS is but maybe it
doesn't matter so let's go ahead and run
this just make sure it runs make sure it
looks like it gives us some sort of
legit number and I'm gonna run it with
my make file actually I'll for clarity
sake I'll know
make file whatever there we go so I'm
just using g plus plus make and looks
like we got a little bit of an error I
need to put this calls in here again
because it's got to be comparing to
something after that and there we go go
ahead and run that again we got another
error looks like we need a semicolon
somewhere where is that at that's line
158 that's right here oh we need this
isn't else--if else--if calls over 200
so there we go looks like we still got
another error one too many parentheses
all right fine
so we'll get rid of that parenthesis and
we'll make one more time how many calls
let's say one call we got to build 200
sounds good 50 calls still got a bill
200 how many calls let's do one 4224
bucks all right let's do 180 245 well
let's do two hundred and 52 or 54 and
there's the new bill okay so that seems
right I'm pretty sure that's right there
we go there's the answer the question I
know they took forever to get started
because I was just trying to figure out
what they were saying and we'll go on to
the next one so there it is I'm gonna
comment all that out not needed anymore
and this next one I think I started
doing this and recorded it and lost the
recording so it's not here for me and
also I don't remember this formula okay
basically says write a program to find
the roots of a quadratic equation of the
type ax squared plus BX plus C where a
is not equal to zero so I had to go look
up this equation and figure it out I
think I just pasted in the solution
ultimately yeah I did okay
so basically if you look up this formula
you'll see that you get some different
situations depending on what your answer
is to begin with when you plug it all in
so you got to do this this thing first
you know all right I don't explain this
it's basically just running through a
formula and if you look up the formula
for this the first thing you do is you
find the what is it find the squares or
something and it depends what your first
answer is on that what you do next
so they just have a little if-else
depending on what D calculates too and
then they just plug in the different
formulas for the different initial
results so the way you find that is you
say let's see what is it called find the
square root C find the roots yeah
finding the roots so if you just go to
Google and go to finding finding roots
of a quadratic equation yeah it's a
there's a video of it we're not gonna
look at the video but basically they're
just running through these formulas
following the pattern with an if/else
afterwards and this is the quad
formula so I don't you'll get it there
I just don't I don't I don't want to try
to unpack math this is really just about
controlling the flow of what that D
equals and then doing the rest as
required by the aquatic formula I hope
I'm saying that all right
and we're going to move on from that but
well I guess I could give it a run so
Henry value of a B and C five four and
three and there we go
routes are imaginary route one is that
or two is that very good so we run it
again we can give it some different
stuff we can give it all once and see
what happens there we go all right so
next one we're gonna add in comment out
number ten so if this next one doesn't
involve complicated math and looking up
a formula because I don't I don't want
to do that live the marks obtained by a
student in five different subjects or
input by the user the student gets a
division as per the following rules
percentage above sixty first division
okay
one hundred fifty to fifty nine second
division percentage 40 49 third division
so there's less than forty fail write a
program to calculate the division
obtained by the student and this is yet
another really awkward use of words so I
don't know who wrote this but there are
in another planet what do you mean by
first division are we dividing by
something are they putting them in
different categories I don't know what
the frick talking about so I don't know
how anybody would know what that means
without having to like clarify and ask
questions so I have to look at this
solution here because I literally don't
know what they mean by first division
other than maybe they want them in that
category is that what they mean the
marks obtained by a student in five
minutes subjects are by the user a user
gets a division as per the following
rules write a program to calculate the
division yeah I literally don't know
what this means
I could read this a million times
I just don't understand why you're
calling it first first / what are you
dividing but I don't get it I literally
can't get this it makes no sense to me
at all so I'm you know this question
makes me feel stupid because it's so
stupid
alright so yeah we just we're gonna take
five different subject scores
I'm guessing their percentage scores
from zero to a hundred that's a guess
well it does say print percentage but
then it also says marks what are the
what do they mean by marks percentage
marks it's just over this website sucks
don't go to this website honestly don't
try to learn off this website clearly
they're really really epic bad at being
clear so I guess that's why I'm here to
rail on them and just try to make sense
of their garbage we literally have to go
look at the logic they use to implement
it to figure out even what the heck
their question means the question is
harder than the solution in this cheese
just take down your website until it's
better you know what are you doing okay
so they enter the marks and then they
make a percentage off of all those five
marks okay so they're just it's just
like five different grades and you
average them all together that's all I
mean take five different percentages and
average them all together how the heck
are we supposed to get that out of here
really come on and look how they write
first is T III and I I advert and see
out fill this is not an else fail you
could you just write fail on this whole
thing my god what okay okay I got it I
got I gotta stop bashing on this whoever
wrote this for a second because it's
it's making me mad so this is obviously
a really easy thing to write first of
all and they didn't do a very good job
of writing it in flow of controlling it
so I'm gonna do better so yeah you just
take five percentage scores and get the
average and then put them in a different
category
or apparently I don't know what world
they live in but for some reason a you
don't fail to you're less than 40
percent I've never never seen school do
that usually it's under fifty nine
percent that you fail but uh you know
epic bad website is epic bad so here we
go so we're just gonna say standard see
out enter enter five percentage scores
all right got that percentage scores and
some serve percentages we're gonna take
in floats of I'll just do s1 for score
one score to notice I'm not using RS or
whatever the F that they would use
alright as they're all going to
automatically initialize to zero if you
want to make sure they do you can you
can do something like this
and since we're declaring them all in
the same line we just have to make sure
we do this after the parentheses okay so
they all start at zero and our five
percentage scores and we'll just we'll
just clear clarify here that is 0 to 100
that way will even say just enter five
scores zero to 100 so we got to do a
standard C n s 1 and s 2 then s 3 then S
4 and S 5 so that's that's kind of okay
I'm doing this wrong I don't know I have
commas there I actually need to do it
this way so this is just gonna prompt
for all these scores in a row separated
by space
hopefully the user doesn't put in bad
input we're not gonna be checking for
bad input if you accidentally put them
back in put just crash your program with
control Z and start again and we also
need to make sure they don't get a score
over 100 probably I would I would think
this doesn't really say the way this is
worded you could give someone a score of
55 million
and be fine because they just don't care
you know but I'm gonna happen assume
okay let's be it this is about flow of
control so let's let's do some flow of
control it gets really really
complicated really fast
normally you design some functions to
check things that way you don't have to
type it all Paul and CL on one line but
I guess we're gonna do that so we're
gonna say if yes yeah we'll just make
this long screw it I'll make it I'll
make it actually half decent so if s
should I make it happen
do I want to err over check I want them
so we if you want to check for errors
like you want to check they put in a
legit number and they're not messing
something else you basically need to
check each of these before continuing
and if they mess one up you either need
to clear it out and reap romped or
something along those lines there'd be
some real flow of control this is just
easy mode badly worded flow of control I
don't know okay we'll do it there bad
way I don't want to I don't want to make
this any longer than it needs to be but
if you're doing this for real it needs
to be longer you've got to check this
stuff you can't risk taking in
completely improper input and then just
continue it you just can't that's not a
good idea in software ever so just so
you know alright but we're gonna we're
gonna not worry about that too much so
we're gonna get these five scores and
the only thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna make a new variable called well
we'll make it a float called average sad
that's what this is it's an average hung
on what the Freak they're calling here
division 1st division 2nd division I
don't know I don't know what they're
calling it gets a division as per the
following please
use use proper wording so people can
actually even understand the question
how hard can it be run it by anyone
there's so many people in the world you
could just say hey Bob I'll give you 10
bucks to read through this and correct
all my terrible grammar and someone
would do it but no they they don't do
that so whatever we're going with it
so we just need to add all these
together and then divide by the amount
of them which is five and that that's it
this is a really little ghetto algorithm
we got them all we divide by five
because there are five and that's that's
the result we want to divide by five dot
F because we want to divide by float
since these are all floats and then
we'll have the average and then we can
just say to them this is all for
spitting out the result really
if average is greater than sixty dot F
who knows do we say first division look
someone's not going to know what that
means they're gonna be nude they're just
gonna say oh you got first division what
it was I mean I got divided by one what
does that mean until really this should
say something like congrats you passed
the class all right
that's that's probably what it should
say cuz he got over he didn't get an F
all right oh wait never mind there F is
at forty so really at the top so even if
you get a 60% you're at the top of the
class and cording to this one first
division maybe this maybe that's how
this guy had everything weighted because
he couldn't do anything logical ever you
know I really didn't expect this to to
turn into a thing about railing
someone's English and stuff but it is
what it is I'm gonna call it like I see
it
and maybe I'm wrong whatever I don't
think I am but I could be so if your
average is greater than 60 okay so if
it's not greater than 60 it's gonna go
down to this next if else in check here
and little say so if it's greater than
50 dot F so that means it's less than 60
but it's greater than 50 more flow of
controlling here and we'll say here
Congrats
you passed the class or whatever it is
just below the top I don't know
something like that sure their second
place basically else if their average is
greater than it looks like 40% here they
still passed but now they're in third
division we're just gonna copy that
whole line double-clicked hit ctrl-c
ctrl-v down here and kind of line this
up there we go and you pass the class
just barely
is that barley or barely I don't know
whatever I'm leaving it and then last
but not least okay let me just be clear
here if it's over 60 Congrats your class
pass the class at top so if it skips
past this because it's less than 60 it's
gonna go this next one see is it over 50
if it's over 50 that means it's
somewhere between 50 but it's definitely
less than 60 because you know skipped
over that one and they're just below it
and then if it skips over this 51 - we
know they've got a less than or 50 so
we're checking okay is it about 40 so if
it is above 40 we say this then if it
still still skips over this one stips or
skipped over this case because it is
less than 40 we know that they failed we
don't even need to check any further
there's no further checks we just we
just do this whatever Congrats you will
just put fail here fail here yep take it
again enjoy wasting your time and money
on school there we go no no no bashing
there hold on a second what it's not
here
it's not yeah it's not here all right
and that's it for that question let's
just run it and make sure it works
make one we got we got an operator wrong
somewhere
oh the C n is backwards so actually I'm
going to just highlight them hit ctrl H
which allows me to do a replace flip the
direction and I'm just gonna replace one
at a time till it gets them all replaced
very good all righty so we're looking
pretty good there let's go ahead and
make this again and there we go it is
running it's gonna ask us for five
scores from zero to 100 of course it
doesn't do checking because you know if
they're not even gonna check their
wording why would they check anything
else whoever wrote this never ever ever
hire the guy that wrote this they will
just ruin your company because you'll
like accidentally pay out people
millions of dollars from their terrible
math and not checking input but you know
we'll go with it these are the percents
and they are allowed
thanks to not understanding anything
logic guy so like I said in reality it's
really important to check that these are
bounded properly this these tutorials
probably aren't going to tell you that
because obviously this guy doesn't care
anything about bounds word bounds logic
bounds anything he's there just copy and
paste even for views and apparently it's
working because here I am I just googled
and got a link to CPP labs and this is
what came up it was like the first link
it's not gonna be hard to make better
ones than this if anyone else wants to
take over that top spot in google you
can you can take these same questions
correct all their English and logic and
it would work fine and you would win so
anyway let's run this with a more legit
case let's say maybe you got a 50 on
your first test a 40 on the second one
and then a 70 and then uh I will say a
19 and then last but not least you bring
it home with a 70 so we get it Congrats
you passed the class just barely so
there's some where
in this 40 to 50 range yeah well that's
gonna do for this episode thanks for
watching thanks for listening to me
rail and this guy's writing and see in
the next episode don't forget to give
this a like subscribe if you wanna see
more videos I'm gonna keep pounding
these out as much as I can hope it helps
somebody out there that is learning it's
what these are for
they're for new people trying to learn
C++ and understand how to how to go
through it peace out